well
[Music]
hello today is tuesday november 3
andrés gonzález greets you and these are the
most important news of the day
a fire in a
house near aia and tropical earl wayne streets is still under investigation
police detectives and firefighters revealed details  As for
what caused the accident, they say that a
woman set her ex-boyfriend's car on fire and
the flames spread to the
house. The firefighters quickly managed to
extinguish the fire
while the police located the
woman who was traveling in her car not far from
the scene.  and she was immediately detained
and the decisive day has arrived here are
some reminders for those
voters who are going to exercise the right
today remind you that you
can still register in person and at
any of the polling places
but remember that you must bring your
identification  there are 125 polling places
throughout clark county the places
will be open from 7 am to
7 pm if you have  a
mail-in ballot can avoid
long lines and deposit it in designated drop boxes
at sites
and concerns of possible
riots and violence are emerging ahead of the
presidential election some businesses in
the city center decided to take
precautions and covered their
establishments with billboards  madera
the same thing has been reported in other
cities across the country here in las vegas the
vice president of the arts district said
he doesn't think that kind of violence will
come here in our city but
still the metro police said they will deploy
additional officers on the streets
now  We are going to review the temperatures
for today we will have an application
for this afternoon so if you are going to
vote remember to bring water to be able to
hydrate the temperatures will be in the
80s well above normal
but it will be cold by the end of
week with an icy front coming
from the Pacific so take care of yourself and
warm up for Saturday and Sunday  Mingo is
all for today I inform you of Andrés González
with an informative hat of Nao Indians
in Spanish
Happy Election Day
[Music]